j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
alors le CSA m'interdit de dire quel est
le livre de Stéphane Guillon où Stéphane
Guillon est sur scène non plus que fait
Stéphane Guillon ce soir avec la
division
vous avez préparé non juste avant de
commencer je voulais dire
Eric de Montgolfier que je vous en veux
un peu voilà parce que depuis que vous
avez mis Bernard Tapie en prison
maintenant il fait l'acteur et c'est
beaucoup plus pénible pour tout le monde
voilà
commence par une bonne nouvelle Cécilia
Sarkozy regarde l'émission Thierry la
semaine dernière je m'interrogeais sur
la sexualité du Petit Nicolas et bien
dès le lendemain Cécilia me répondait
dans Libération Sarkozy c'est le pied
alors nouveau test Nicolas en a-t-il une
grosse peut-être une réponse demain
est-ce que la taille c'est important
quand même
vie sociale les 100 papiers s'installe
chez ni [ __ ] ni soumise moi si j'étais
sans papier ce qui n'est déjà pas très
rigolo quitte à m'installer quelque part
je choisirais une [ __ ] soumise
aéroport
aéroport nouvelle restriction
draconienne tous les liquides sont
interdits en cabine résultat civils ne
pourra plus prendre l'avion avec Martha
barrière qui est quand même très très
liquide
politique dans VSD Le Pen se réfère à
Clémenceau c'est vrai il y a beaucoup de
points communs entre Le Pen et le
porte-avion ce sont deux vieux raphiaux
l'un n'a plus de radar l'autre est
borgne en 99 le Clémenceau perd son
hélice Le Pen sa prostate turbine au
point mort état sanitaire détestable et
bourré d'amiante l'autre et xénophobe
les deux sont bretons malheureusement
les mouettes ne chient que sur le
Clémenceau
[Applaudissements]
attention
attention si là était désarmée l'autre
peut encore frapper le couler très vite
toujours dans VSD le journal analyse la
gestuelle des politiques moi j'ai vu des
titres de films Laurent Fabius dans iti
et les autres
Le Pen affreux ça les méchants Philippe
de Villiers
Jacques Chirac à bout de souffle
François Hollande ma femme s'appelle
revient
fait divers encore deux bébés en moins
cette semaine un noyer façon Villemin un
congelé façon Courjault il n'y a pas que
la Star Ac pour devenir connue pour
endiguer cette tendance le journal Le
Parisien vous propose pour 12 euros une
fausse une avec la photo de votre petit
une façon d'épater vos potes sans
trucider bébé
attendez après c'est pire
à ce propos la mère du petit David a
tenté de se suicider au liquide
vaisselle elle s'est ratée bah oui si
vous avalez du liquide vaisselle faut
courir et boire en même temps il faut
que ça mousse sinon ça marche pas
voilà
première sortie publique d'Isabelle
dinoir la greffée du visage elle boit
elle fume elle rigole bientôt la reprise
d'une vie sexuelle mais là la famille du
donneur s'inquiète c'est quand même la
bouche de notre fille trop tard donner
ses données
[Rires]
mondialisation la société
Ikea emploi des travailleurs asiatiques
payés 0,90 centimes d'euros la journée
leur slogan c'est IKEA est là IKEA est
là pour les [ __ ] la deuxième partie du
slogan est moins connue
attendez tirer ce qu'on est en train de
me dire que l'audience de l'émission
s'effrite légèrement donc je vais poser
une question non je posais une question
à Michel Bernier pour que l'audio soit
prenne c'est où vous permettez
Michel je voudrais tordre le coup à la
rumeur il paraît que vous avez une
aventure avec Zinédine Zidane
c'est bon l'audience reprend c'est bon
on a sauvé l'émission j'aimerais bien
télévision on commence par une devinette
sur la table de nuit de Pascal Sevran il
y a quelque chose qui fait mal au cul
à votre avis Thierry qu'est-ce que c'est
je ne peux pas le dire maintenant et
bien il le dit lui-même dans la presse
j'ai mis la photo de Sarkozy à côté de
celle du Mitterrand c'est vrai que ça
fait mal au cul
on se demandait comment Olga la chienne
de Michel Drucker pouvait endurer chaque
semaine l'enregistrement de Vivement
Dimanche notamment un spécial Shella
pauvre bête et bien on a la réponse les
chiens souffrent aussi d'Alzheimer pour
elle à chaque fois c'est son premier
Vivement Dimanche
people il y a 15 jours Madonna adopté
David un petit Malawi et bien cette
semaine Lolo Brigida 79 ans adopte
Xavier Rigaud un jeune avocat de 34 ans
son cadet il est propre il mange tout
seul et surtout il est formé presque
on termine par un voici particulièrement
immonde cette semaine le journal
inaugure une nouvelle rubrique la
torture morale la recette prenait
Jacques Martin qui est paralysé dans un
établissement médicalisé puis achevez-le
en publiant des photos de sa femme
batifolant avec un jeune homme fringant
dans le même temps voici offre une
cafetière au lecteur qui s'abonne pour
les filtres utilisés du papier cure
vieux truc de scout ou c'est encore
mieux le journal lui-même voilà la
semaine prochaine
bonsoir Stéphane vous connaissez tout le
monde
voilà Stéphane Guillon qui vient de
publier un livre dont je n'ai pas le
droit de donner le titre non à cause du
CSA Stéphane Guillon qui est sur scène
tous les soirs j'ai pas le droit de dire
où non plus à cause du CSA en revanche
moi j'ai pas rancunier je vais donner
l'adresse du CSA c'est 43 quai André
Citroën et
[Applaudissements]
allez-y c'est un endroit formidable quoi
on passe un très très bon moment voilà
alors Stéphane votre revue de presse de
la série politique on commence par un
scoop ce matin une cassette de Ségolène
Royal nous est parvenu des images très
intimes la Madone du PS déguisé en
enseignante s'accouple avec François
Hollande habillé en directeur d'école
des propos très crus vas-y François
traite-moi de feignasse fais-moi un RTT
j'adore ça également un poster nous est
adressé attention c'est un collector
madame
qu'à Anne Sinclair en tenue sadomaso
waouh
[Applaudissements]
dommage que Strauss-Kahn est perdu vous
auriez été tous les soirs à l'Élysée
Thierry voilà en revanche le couple Le
Pen Jany et Jean-Marie sont à la
campagne
cette politique toujours Bernadette
Chirac souhaite un troisième mandat pour
son mari vous avez vu comme il est en
forme ces critères c'est vrai hier
Jacques a fait un puzzle entier avec
Jacques Martin et Paul-Loup Sulitzer
venu jouer avec lui à l'Élysée
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut voir les deux photos
ensemble Bernadette et anne sinclair
à chaque pied jaune un coup de fouet
ça donne envie de casser sa tirelire
société les prisons de la honte titre Le
Parisien drogue viole bizutage
surpopulation faut pas exagérer alors ce
qui est surtout dur c'est la télé
allumée 24 heures sur 24 TF1 en boucle
ça explique le nombre de suicides
se faire [ __ ] en regardant Bataille
et Fontaine c'est la double peine
vie pratique une taxe écolo fait flamber
les prix plus 13 euros pour un
congélateur conséquences depuis mercredi
les nourrissons sont rangés dans le
jardin
c'est toujours pire
médecine le Viagra Féminin disponible
dès janvier malheureusement des effets
secondaires sont à craindre acné et
pilosité abondantes si votre femme a de
nouveau envie de vous c'est vous qui
n'avez plus envie d'elle sport
sport Sarkozy a remis la médaille de
bronze à la conductrice du bus incendie
à Marseille si elle avait été brûlée
avec son bus elle aurait été médaille
d'or à ce niveau de la compétition ça se
joue à rien
c'est vrai entre un deuxième et un
premier squat c'est un coup de
bouledogue
c'est vrai
people une info gala Paris Hilton dort
dans un lit à 20000 dollars quitte à
coucher avec une conne autant que la
literie soit top
[Musique]
dans le magazine Femme Actuelle Isabelle
Giordano raconte Monica Bellucci déjà
Monica Bellucci c'est chiant raconté par
les abeilles Giordano
[Applaudissements]
un très beau reportage sur les années
yéyé notamment une photo de Mike Brant
avec son doberman quand Mike a sauté par
sa fenêtre le chien a suivi
c'est con d'être fidèle
Estelle
Estelle Lefébure propose un calendrier
très coquin pour l'Unicef faites-vous
une petite douceur tout en aidant les
plus démunis la branlette humanitaire un
nouveau concept
UNICEF
UNICEF toujours ce soir TF1 fête les 60
ans de l'organisation une cérémonie
doublée d'une expérience scientifique
pour égaler le coefficient intellectuel
d'une animatrice brune TF1 utilisera les
cerveaux de deux animatrices blondes
pour l'occasion 500 petits choristes
chanteront ça aurait été chouette
d'inviter Michael Jackson tous les mots
chanter avec Bambi prendre un enfant par
la main d'Yves Duteil ça aurait eu de la
gueule à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
dépêchez-vous vous allez au théâtre
c'est vrai
on commence par la politique dans le
Figaro Ségolène Royal et comparé à
Hillary Clinton donc Clinton c'est
François Hollande dans ce cas qui fait
Monica Levinsky ça c'est typique du
Figaro ils ne vont jamais au bout de
leur raisonnement dans Libération une
lettre de Dominique Voynet à Nicolas
Hulot tuer des nôtres c'est pas juste tu
tries tes ordures tu économise l'eau tu
manges bio et au final tu reçois une
déclaration de Dominique Venet ça donne
envie d'acheter un 4 4 diesel
le ministère de la Santé s'intéresse aux
produits Ushuaïa le spray à base de
limonène provoque des cancers chez le
rat qui va aller parfumer un rat avec un
déodorant ou soyez on n'est pas con
Dominique bonnet aucun déodorant non
une info du Parisien un des fils de
Philippe de Villiers mis en examen pour
viol sur son frère cadet c'est embêtant
Philippe de Villiers le garant de la
famille modèle si ses enfants se violent
entre eux c'est comme si Le Pen hébergé
des sans-papiers comme si Dieudonné
jouait son spectacle en Israël on perd
nos repères et en même temps élevé en
Vendée par Philippe de Villiers seuls
sortis de l'année le Puy du Fou est-ce
que tu ne finis pas par te taper ton
frère
[Applaudissements]
politique internationale une exposition
sur les droits de l'homme à Pékin en
Chine sujet évité tiennent à demain la
torture et il y a aussi la peine de mort
3500 fusillés par an 3500 c'est pas
grand chose ça fait un dixième du Parc
des Princes à peine disons le virage
nord on a qu'à supprimer les plus cons
un remake de Flipper le dauphin flipper
et Poutine Poutine zigouille des
journalistes torture des tchétchène et
flipper s'en branle
après les dauphins les poissons lune
Evelyne Thomas a été frappé par son mari
Christophe oui c'est son choix de lui en
mettre une
prudence quand même le Botox plus des
baigne elle va bientôt ressembler à
Gianni dans ma histoire
un an je passe
société inauguration d'une stèle pour
les victimes du Concorde le 25 juillet
200013 retraités allemands partent pour
les Caraïbes une arrivée inattendue à
Gonesse un hôtel miteux des valises
éventrées pas de clés mais une
température de 300 degrés la femme de
chambre absente soit disant écrasée par
un réacteur
manifestation devant le siège des
surgelés Picard s'ils se mettent en
grève attention plus de surgelés ça veut
dire plus de place dans le congélateur
déménagères et toutes les naissances à
venir c'est bon
une info Paris Match les femmes ont pris
le pouvoir sans doute mais il y en a pas
une qui est [ __ ] un Thierry regardez
peut-être la grande à gauche non
[Rires]
télévision les papy flics en fin de
course faut pas exagérer un Navajo perd
sa prostate a fait 45% de parts de
marché
merci c'est gentil
oui porno à la télé le CSA interdit les
films X sans capote sans parole on peut
déjà plus boire plus fumé prendre une
fille à moitié bourré que bec à son
charme
dans VSD des photos très dures
d'Américains mutilés et un français vous
reconnaissez les béquilles ce sont
celles de Michel Drucker
bah oui j'y peux rien pendant quatre
pages Olga sa chienne témoigne mon
maître est un grand angoissé Michel n'a
pas fait le Vietnam ni les rack mais
l'ORTF est visiblement ça laisse des
séquelles
un peu de douceur maintenant ma
sélection de Noël pour les petites
filles sorties du livre officiel Miss
France on apprend qu'à l'hôpital le
sourire de Miss France aide les enfants
dans leur guérison ouais moi j'aurais
plutôt peur que ça les achève fillette
si on tape ce manuel appelle Carole
Bouquet Enfance Maltraitée
un spécialiste du billard créé un jeu de
boules à l'effigie de nos politiques
pour tous ceux qui rêvent de mettre un
coup de queue à Ségolène Royal
le jeu idéal
jouait toujours pour les déguisements de
monstres choisissez Hulk capitaine
crochet ou Dark Vador Le Pen Dieudonné
et Georges Frêche c'est de très mauvais
goût enfin Barbie sort son coffret mamie
le problème c'est son prix mais bon avec
vous avez 10 sacs de pièces jaunes le
château de Bity un compte au Japon c'est
pas mal la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
politique le journal Le Parisien
décrypte la gestuelle de Ségolène Royal
alors je les cite ses yeux d'érable
souvent vers le front comme si elle
cherchait l'inspiration aux portes de
son intelligence vous connaissez le
dealer du Parisien Thierry à mon avis il
a de bons produits
jeudi en Une du Figaro Sarkozy candidat
pour une rupture tranquille
j'ai le souvenir de sa rupture avec
Cécilia ça n'a pas été tranquille
tranquille d'ailleurs y aurait-il à
nouveau de l'eau dans le gaz au sapin de
Noël de l'Élysée Cécilia est venu seul
avec son petit garçon et mignon
pour obtenir ces parrainages Philippe de
Villiers drague les mers ruraux alors
plusieurs promesses non au droit de vote
des étrangers non au mariage homosexuel
en revanche si j'habite en Vendée dans
une famille catho de 7 enfants un père
qui dit une connerie à la minute et j'ai
le droit de violer mon frère cadet pour
me distraire là c'est
trois enfants myopathes ont passé une
journée entière avec Barthez pauvre
gosse c'est pas parce que t'as plus de
jambes que tu as plus de cerveau
société
Air France crée sa compagnie charter
Transavia attention les compagnies
charters sont moins sûrs pour cette
raison après le crash de la flash
Airlines les 148 corps ont été rapatriés
sur vol régulier aucune turbulence
musique classique à bord zéro plainte à
l'arrivée la chirurgie esthétique
discount se fait également un malheur à
l'étranger pour 20% moins cher
faites-vous la bouche d'Emmanuel Béart
les oreilles de Dany Boon le menton des
frères Bogdanov de très belles réussites
Mickey Rourke Catherine Deneuve it
un an après la première greffe partielle
du visage une équipe américaine prépare
une greffe totale la seule bémol la
mobilité des paupières n'est pas
garantie en même temps si c'est raté ce
que c'est pas mieux d'avoir les yeux
fermés
people Miss Limousin veut représenter la
surdité c'est pas mal pour représenter
la connerie on l'a vu elles sont déjà
beaucoup
surdité toujours le nouveau CD de Carla
Bruni sort en janvier le 23
l'élection Miss France approche cette
semaine les miss était dans les Baléares
une info gala Jean-Pierre Foucault les a
auditionnés personnellement audition
orale pour Miss Tahiti Jean-Pierre
aramet comme elle est enduite de Monoï
tu l'entreprends dans la salle de bain
que tu l'as fini dans la cuisine
jamais fini personne
disparition Robert Altman Philippe
Noiret francis Giraud nous quitte
malheureusement Berlusconi sentir
sympa là-haut nous laisse que la merde
cette semaine
[Rires]
or la direction du Paris Saint-Germain
durciton alors cette fois encore les
frais d'hospitalisation du supporter
blessé seront prises en charge avec en
plus quelques cadeaux un fanion des
chaussettes bon un bandana mais au
prochain coup c'est fini comme
iPad nous réclamer une écharpe on est
bien d'accord là il faut être les
petites ta fioles du Front national
jeunesse ça rigole plus là
sport toujours
inquiétude à Roland-Garros après cette
déclaration de Vincent Delerm je rêve
d'être ramasseur de balles
le temps qu'il les renvoie un match peut
difficilement durer trois jours
Fabrice Luchini sort les Fables de La
Fontaine en CD alors en tournage avec la
Piche Fabrice n'a pas pu venir Thierry
je vais essayer à ma manière de de le
remplacer
Salut les Terriens là c'est génial un
décor d'une sobriété monacale le palais
de Versailles à côté c'est un bungalow
Ardisson sur Canal la boucle est bouclée
le samedi square Thierry intérro est-ce
que sucer s'est trompé 4 heures plus
tard avec le film X on a la réponse oui
tu sais c'est tromper vas-y prends-la tu
la sens et là là on comprend on comprend
les lumières tamisées les miroirs au mur
les chandeliers Ardisson habillés en
noir on lui laisse son ticket de
vestiaire enfin un décor où ça baise
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup j'aime Bruno j'aime
beaucoup Bruno Gaccio j'adore gacio ça
sur le service public Caroli se suicide
elles sont bonnes les terriers
c'est énorme MERCI
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ma chérie
Stéphane Guillon vous allez voir son
spectacle à Nadine vachement bien son
spectacle on a pas le droit de dire où
c'est mais c'est très très bien faut
lire son livre aussi on a pas le droit
de donner le titre maintenant c'est très
très bien voilà donc faut se renseigner
on se retrouve après la pub avec
Stéphane Guillon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Stéphane Guillon
politique François Bayrou lance son
slogan de campagne un autre chemin après
la rupture tranquille de Sarkozy jouer à
notre concours le slogan le plus con un
détour en ligne droite un raccourci plus
long le gagnant passe une journée avec
Stevie
pour se détendre le week-end dernier
Sarkozy était à Eurodisney une aubaine
pour les enfants avoir un des nains de
Blanche-Neige en chair et en os François
Bayrou aussi voulait y aller mais comme
il a pris un autre chemin
il s'est retrouvé de l'autre côté au
péage de Saint-Arnoult
au gymnase Japy à Paris Ségolène Royal
s'adressait aux femmes voilées mutilées
excisées violées écrasé alors on peut
concourir dans plusieurs catégories
madame Carlier par exemple était voilée
le jour de son mariage puis écraser lors
de sa nuit neuf avec Guy
avec la mort prochaine d'Augusto
Pinochet et tout un savoir-faire qui va
disparaître tirant sanguinaire un métier
qui n'intéresse plus nos jeunes jadis on
se transmettait la charge grand-père
était un [ __ ] père était un [ __ ] je
suis un [ __ ] Barbie polpote Milosevic
bientôt Saddam Hussein plus aucun client
pour mettre Vergès une idée de
reconversion
avocat à la reine de France un poste
très con mais moins exposé
Russie faut relancer la natalité un
concours de beauté de femmes enceintes
également le concours du plus beau
chauve pour relancer les ventes de
polonium
[Rires]
bon plan samedi dernier je vais vous
parler de chirurgie esthétique discount
30% moins cher à l'étranger et bien
encore mieux cette semaine au Maroc on
pouvait s'offrir une chirurgie faciale
complète pour le prix d'un billet
d'autocar
tandis c'est pire après
technologie le gouvernement veut
généraliser la télévision sur téléphone
mobile génial pouvoir regarder la télé
dans la rue tu sors d'un pipe chaud tu
mets la Méthode Cauet tu restes dans la
même ambiance
people Chimène Badi rêve d'Amérique
est-ce que l'Amérique rêve de Chimène
Badi
George Clooney a perdu son cochon
l'animal aveugle souffrait d’arthrite
alors nous aussi on en a ici il a perdu
sa prostate il est borgne
mais
malheureusement il tient le coup
Pascal Sevran a déclaré au journal
Nice-Matin qu'il fallait stériliser la
moitié de la planète dommage que sa
maman n'ait pas eu cette idée en 44
on termine par le sport déclaration de
Jean-François l'amour au jeu
paralympiques les primes des athlètes
handicapées seront équivalentes à celles
des athlètes valides c'est normal le
spectacle est top le basket pour nain
avec un système de trampoline pour
accéder au panier si l'athlète rentre
avec le ballon le point kond double le
Walter polo pour paraplégique toutes les
minutes les fauteuils sont hissés à la
surface en cas de faute on replonge
l'athlète le tir à l'arc pour non voyant
exceptionnellement l'accès aux tribunes
est gratuit
à la semaine prochaine merci
politique après la couverture de Paris
Match dédié à Nicolas Sarkozy intitulé
un destin en marche d'autres couvertures
d'une neutralité exemplaire sont à
l'étude le géant au cœur tendre l'idole
des banlieues le prince charmant de
Cécilia à propos de Cécilia le même
magazine écrit derrière un physique de
stars se cache une subtile conseillère
il y a un an la subtile conseillère se
cachait aux États-Unis dans les bras
d'un publicitaire une info Paris Match
depuis le directeur de l'époque pointe
aux ASSEDIC bien fait en Russie alors
qu'il est il serait chauve
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours d'après Le Figaro
Ségolène est plus écolo que Hulot c'est
vrai à la maison Ségolène fait très
gaffe pour économiser la lessive
François Hollande ne met que des
Bermudes
économie enfin une vraie mesure sociale
l'État veut améliorer le classement des
palaces on pourrait passer de quatre
étoiles à 5 étoiles luxes cela dit au
niveau des campings il y a encore des
améliorations celui-ci est au pied de
Beaubourg c'est très central par rapport
à un camping en bordure de périphérique
je mettrai une étoile en plus
société un sondage hyper intéressant du
Parisien nous apprend que 23% d'entre
nous rêvent de réveillonner avec Mimie
Mathy faire gaffe quand même qu'elle
reparte pas avec le déguisement des
enfants
Pascal Sevran Pascal Sevran garde son
boulot à France 2 mais comme d'un
avertissement il y a une vraie éthique
sur le service public refuser
d'abandonner la présentation d'une
émission sur Paris Première vous êtes
viré en revanche si vous dites la [ __ ]
des noirs est responsable de la famine
en Afrique on vous garde cela dit un
avertissement à France que ça ne rigole
pas au bout du troisième Pascal pourrait
perdre sa place de parking
[Applaudissements]
on en met pas là dimanche dans son
émission Pascal a chanté avec Patrick
Bruel que reste-t-il de nos amours pas
grand chose quand on a stérilisé la
moitié de la planète
après l'élection Miss France prix du
bébé Cadum 2007 pour gagner il devait
être joufflu potelé lustré et rayonnant
donc tout ce qui était bébé congelé noyé
brûlé c'est pas la peine la société
Picard réfléchit à un concours parallèle
sport
championnat d'Europe consécration pour
Laure Manaudou 20 ans après l'échec du
petit Grégory dans la Vologne l'or
réconcilit la France avec la natation
humanitaire deux ans après le tsunami
30% des dons seulement ont été
redistribuées Natacha Amal qui dans la
catastrophe avait perdu une paire de ton
Prada toujours pas été indemnisé moi
c'est la dernière fois que je dois dire
on termine par une lettre d'un
téléspectateur après l'élection d'une
missourde aura-t-on une Miss aveugle non
on voit le blanc des yeux c'est moche
faut que le handicap reste esthétique
dernière minute on vient de la prendre
Johnny s'installe en Suisse alors
bientôt l'organisation d'un Suisse ton
pour aider les jeunes artistes qui
chantent ici à aller s'installer en
Suisse comme Aznavour Patricia Kaas ou
Marie Laforêt à la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup salut merci
la parole est à Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
Arnaud Montebourg rappelait alors de par
la direction du PS pour une plaisanterie
sur les talonnettes de Sarkozy bah oui
mais bon l'humoriste maison Ops Georges
chacun son boulot
international joyeux Noël
80% des jouets vendus en France
proviennent des usines chinoises coûte
fabrication d'une Barbie 0,35 centimes
d'euro bon cela dit comme ce sont des
enfants qui les assemblent le temps
qu'il les monte ils en profitent
international toujours 25 français
présents à l'hôtel au lit de vinco a été
empoisonné au polonium qui sont-ils des
non circulent Barthez Fabien KOF
Jean-Pierre et blanc Michel
social campagne anti-sidate Johnny
Hallyday nous questionne est-ce que vous
aimeriez autant ma gueule si j'étais
séropositif bah oui bien sûr ici ça nous
pose aucun problème cela dit dans une
petite station de sports d'hiver Suisse
où tout le monde se connaît ça risque
d'être plus emmerde
social toujours la bonne action de
Laetitia Hallyday acheté un ange
Marionnaud pour aider les enfants
défavorisés quand un résidence Suisse
vous donne un conseil de charité
publique écoutez-le
le directeur de Décathlon est fier que
ces tentes soient en ville une phrase
prononcée déjà par Bertrand Delanoë lors
de la Gay Pride
sport
74 supporters blessés lors d'un match de
foot à Dakar le PSG porte plainte pour
plagiat
et on Nathalie Marquay la femme de
Jean-Pierre Pernaut pourrait animer un
magazine de jardinage juste avant que
j'étais de son mari Nathalie Alain verte
lors de l'été 2005 elle est partie en
classe nature avec Daniel Ducruet au
programme binage labourager
mon côté grosse tête
Marie Drucker attire les curieux depuis
la révélation de sa liaison avec
François Baroin 600 000 personnes de
plus ont regardé son JT bien nous aussi
si Ardisson couchait avec Michel a lieu
Marie on gagnerait des téléspectateurs
une relation extraterrestre
si vous détestez un membre de votre
famille offrait le nouvel album de Mimie
Mathy écrit par Patrick Fiori double
peine
cadeau pourri toujours l'intégrale de la
Fontaine récité par Luchini pour faire
chier sa belle-mère y a pas mieux et
puis il y a quelques jours de Noël
scandale dans le monde magique de la BD
l'heure du tournage d'Astérix aux Jeux
Olympiques des [ __ ] auraient été
fournies sur le film c'est pas grave
faut juste changer le nom des acteurs
sodomiques éjaculix c'est cunnilingix
[Applaudissements]
on termine avec le magazine Galak qui
célèbre les bébés de l'année celui de
Tom Cruise de la rue Angelina Jolie en
revanche rien sur les trois bébés
d'Isabelle courgeot 3 bébés congelés sur
papier glacé ça aurait eu de la gueule
une certaine frilosité chez gala joyeux
Noël à tous merci merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innaharditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu